and house democrats didn't just busy
themselves with pushing through these
idiotic commissions
they also voted to kill a resolution
from minority leader kevin mccarthy
to end the obscene and idiotic
chambers mask mandate but many in the
gop including florida congressman brian
mast
well they seek to follow the science and
were met with resistance for doing so
florida congressman brian mass joins me
now congressman uh the dems who voted
against
removing the mask theater from the
chamber
are the same ones some of them are elise
who want
to hand power uh you know want to hand
power
for this unwieldy commission correct
yeah
they don't care about anything else
other than control right if science
uh doesn't support it then they'll just
lie in their commission
right if they really wanted a fair
account of anything about january 6
then they would have done that before
they did an impeachment hearing that's
like putting somebody's head in the
guillotine
and then saying hey let's go look for
some facts as their heads laying in a
basket
well i think more americans are
beginning to kind of
wake up to what's been going on here
with a lot of these rules
but nancy pelosi made it her personal
mission today
to try to shame non-mask wearers watch
members and staff are currently required
to wear masks at all times the house is
following the guidance
of the attending physician who has
stated that the present mask
requirements
other guidelines remain unchanged in the
hall of the house until all members
and the floor staff are fully vaccinated
congressman is this really the doctor's
orders
or is this just pelosi and another power
glab or grab or like
flexing her muscles if i can call them
that
if it's pelosi it's always a power grab
that's the
the name of the game with her you asked
in an earlier segment how can they get
away with always being wrong
they don't care about if they're right
they only care about being in control
and that's why they end up wrong every
time down the line and they sent me my
little envelope today
saying oh here you know here you go
you're fine here's your fine and the
next time it's going to be 2 500
they don't care they just want the
control whether it's through science
whether it's through lying
whether it's through hurting you in your
pocketbook and trying to get trying to
get you to comply
that's the name of the game well the cnn
is saying that you're not
following the cdc guidance watch
they are trying to claim victor that a
mass mandate is not in keeping with the
new cdc guidelines so
they either don't understand the new
guidelines or they're actively flouting
them
dr fauci clarified that the guidelines
are for fully
vaccinated people congressman is
is that your read of the situation i
like to think i understand them but
it wouldn't really matter to me if i was
flouting them as well i've been
vaccinated
i'm told that i am now safe from getting
this so as a substantial
portion of the house and the staff let
people live their lives it goes so far
beyond this though
this is ripples well down the chain
because right now you have schools
saying
can they make a segment of the
population that is barely affected by
this
get vaccines that we don't even know the
long-term effects of can employers
make their employees share their health
information and if they don't they can
be fired
and can the american people be fined for
not
for not complying with wearing a mask
those are the ripples that come down
from washington right now yeah well and
you wonder why we're talking about the
coming climate lockdowns
if this stuff could happen for 15 months
lord knows what they're going to try
next congressman thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else